just like we communicate with each other
using cellphone
whatsapp etc neurons in our brain
communicate with each other by an
electrical signal known as action
potential or spikes now if you're
watching this video the visual input is
going into your brain making your
neurons of your eyes the optical track
to fire and that information is relayed
to the higher higher cortex where the
visual information is processed and if
you're also listening to me then your
auditory neurons are firing and sending
this information to your auditory cortex
so neurons spikes that means the spike
is action potential which is nothing but
a change in voltage over time so the
change is from resting membrane
potential to a positive membrane
potential of last 30 millivolts
this Delta change in voltage about 100
millivolt change in voltage is known as
the action potential so question is
whether we can measure the action
potential from the neurons or not it
turns out we can use
electrophysiological methods to measure
the action potentials and that could
tell us about various biophysical
properties of the neuron including
capacitance conductance firing frequency
input resistance and firing pattern a
combination of all of these biophysical
parameters can tell about several
aspects of the neuronal physiology and
how the neuron is coding for the
information which would be decoded in
the higher brain center now here is a
typical patch clamp setup with a
microscope and you can see with the
microscope there is a camera attached by
which you can real-time image the neuron
from where you are recording
there are setups for electrode
stimulating and recording electrode
which are held in position by
micromanipulators and you have a bunch
of amplifiers several power supplies etc
etcetera and a screen where the
recording is displayed
so here is even closer view of that rig
where you can see the micromanipulators
is holding the patch electrodes so these
electrodes are recording electrodes you
could have another from another side you
could have a stimulating electrode which
would give current inputs so now this is
the stripped-down version of the patch
clamp setup so most important part is
this recording electrode which is
connected to the amplifier because these
currents or voltage whatever it is
recorded is miniscule so it has to be
amplified in order to detect and that
goes to a data acquisition system and
goes to a computer which which displays
the recording in real time now the first
and foremost criteria of the patch clamp
is to establish a patch so how to
establish a patch in a patch clamp
method the electrode is poured down
towards the cell membrane and gentle
suction is applied once the suction is
proper the membrane resistance would
increase and reach in order of 1 Giga
ohm we call it Giga ohm seal let's see
how to understand whether Giga ohm seal
is established or not this seal is
important because if it seal is not
proper then there would be iron leakage
and the proper recording won't be
happening so first of all when you are
approaching with your electrode towards
the neuron you you use a positive
pressure and you inject a small current
so you definitely get a linear response
a small change in voltage as well now
what you could do when you just reach
and about to establish a Giga home seal
then you inject the same amount of
current if the Giga ohm seal or
resistance is so high in order of Giga
ohm then the recorded voltage deflection
would be very very low because your
resistance is in order of Giga ohms now
gentle suction can break open the
membrane of the cell and thereby you
would see a small capacitive transients
which results due to the discharging of
the capacitor and capacitor so and
thereby you can understand a proper gig
on silva's
and now the inside of the pipette and
the inside of the cell is continuous
this configuration is one of the
important configuration most used
configuration in electrophysiology known
as wholesale recording if we talk about
wholesale recording which is a subgroup
of patch-clamp
techniques then wholesale recording
could be used or operated in two modes
one is voltage clamp mode another is
current clamp mode each has its own
unique advantages using a voltage clamp
mode you can keep the voltage constant
so the voltage parameter is in your hand
you can keep the voltage constant or in
other terms you can hold the voltage at
certain millivolts and measure the
currents whereas in the current clamp
mode you can keep the current constant
and measure the changing voltages so
when you need to record the action
potentials which is basically Delta
changing voltage you use a current clamp
configuration so a current clamp mode
under wholesale recording so and when
you need to record the currents the
ionic currents then voltage clamp method
is important now voltage clamp method or
this overall patch clamp method has
several variants so let me discuss
briefly about them so first of all one
variant is called a still attached
recording when you establish the Giga
ohm seal but doesn't break the membrane
so single macroscopic and microscopic
currents could be recorded in this
configuration the second configuration
is the wholesale configuration and
mostly used configuration where the
inside of the pipette and the inside of
the cell membrane is in equilibrium and
they are like continuous so in this
configuration we can record properties
like action potential and macroscopic
currents etcetera etcetera now two other
variants which are critic interesting
and important for specific application
for example inside out recording in
inside out recording the inside out
recording configuration could be
achieved by simply pulling your pipette
apart when the Giga ohm scene
is when the Giga home seal is a present
so that would create a patch of the
membrane to be detached from the neuron
now since the inside of the ion channels
is not exposed to the environment you
can study the properties of several
molecules and how they regulate this
channel conductance so that is the
utility of this inside-out recording now
the outside out recording is another
important thing so in a whole silk
configuration if you pull the pipette
backward then a portion of the membrane
is going to be retracted and it would be
rejoined and now the outside of the ion
channels are outside of the membrane is
exposed to the environment now that
could be dipped into several solution
maybe this kind of configuration would
be very useful to study role of several
neurotransmitter on channel conductances
so all these kind of several variant of
patch clamp techniques has its own
advantages and disadvantages but one of
the most used one is the wholesale patch
clamp recording that can be operated in
either voltage clamp mode or in current
clamp mode now let's say you know
wholesale configuration you inject a
negative current and you would get force
capacitive small currents and when it
reaches the threshold it would start
firing action potential and you can
nicely represent this data in form of
injected current and voltage and plot an
IV relationship remember when you are
going towards more depolarized you are
giving more depolarizing current it is
giving rise to your action potential but
why do you want to inject a
hyperpolarized current it is important
to increase the current because in the
hyperpolarizing side you can calculate
one important biophysical property known
as input resistance which would tell you
how your how much leaking is is in the
membrane or how and also that parameter
is important because depending upon
input resistance it tells us that how
much the neuron is likely to fire or how
easy for the neuron is to generate an
action put
so these parameters I would be
discussing in other videos so but what
is the importance of this action
potential it turns out that our brain is
a decoder of these actions informations
inside these action potentials and it
turns out let's say a spy risk trying to
fight you and you are getting freaked
out and your fear neurons are firing
like hell so after the time there could
be changes in inside these neurons which
would change in biophysical properties
of the neuron or conductive properties
of the neuron let's say you seen the
spider for the second time and somebody
is able to record from your brain then
you would see a potentiated response
your whole firing rate versus input
current curve would shift leftward in
simplest word that same amount of
current is now given a heightened
response or a potentiated response so
that's why this property is about action
potential firing firing frequency firing
rate can give us can tell us so much
about how our brain can function not
only that it turns out the information
about sensory environment is decoded by
the firing rate inside our brain for
example the information about the order
intensity or order quality which is
present in our environment is actually
decoded by the olfactory neurons in the
higher brain olfactory higher brain
sector neutrons by its firing rate so
firing rate and firing pattern in real
time it turns out the odors which are
very similar have very similar firing
trains so that is interesting so the not
only the amplitude of action potential
but the frequency of the action
potential the the interspike interval of
the action potential carrying a huge
amount of information about neuronal
coding so that is pretty interesting so
if you like my video give me a quick
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe and keep on watching these
whole video series where I would be
describing several electrophysiological
properties and how they are relevant for
neuron to work and how that could be
interesting for coatings
three modalities thank you